dr. Steven Chu welcome back to new value
a week dialogue thank you I think it is
the third time you're here isn't it it's
the third time for noble week maybe four
or five other times for mine and friends
of mine know what someone told me that
it is is it your wife's birthday coming
up here and you have decided that this
is a very good way of celebrating a
birthday is that true she was she was
born on December tenth and on 1997 she
said so I said happy birthday and she
said it's a nice birthday present how
can you top that I hope she's as happy
as we are having you back from time to
time you have a very unique background
not only because you're I guess the in
official record holder in number of
nabol week dialogue attendances that you
have a background both as of course a
world-renowned scientist being awarded
the nobel prize in physics in 1997 but
you also served as the United States
Secretary of Energy between 2009 and
2013 can I ask in which of those two
roles do you feel that you have
contributed most to society or to use
the words of Alfred Nobel conferred the
greatest benefit to mankind you know I
it really depends on time of day I think
you know in in public office there are
many many things one can do many of the
things are behind the radar screen it's
not you don't see in the press but you
see it in action and and that was very
rewarding on the other hand you also see
things that in science that one might
have started a decade or three decades
ago that have a life of their own and
are growing just just one bit of irony I
got my mobile prize for laser and
cooling trapping of atoms at the time I
was doing the work it wasn't clear what
the applications were turns out one of
the applications might be a satellite
mission
that can help monitor changes in water
tables and in glaciers through satellite
in the most sensitive way possible
they're in Thomas doing research I had
no idea that would be an application
right Isabella Levin I know nothing
about your wedding anniversaries and I
don't think you are noble Lord yet that
you are of course the deputy prime
minister of Sweden you are the minister
of international development cooperation
and climate and the spokes person for
the Green Party but before you entered
the sort of the political scene you were
well-known journalist and multi I guess
awarded author for the book the silent
sea and was awarded the grand prize of
journalism in 2007 I guess in that book
you are I guess it's fair to say very
critical towards politicians and you're
rather upset about them and you think
it's so easy to solve the problems I
even think that you say in the book that
hangar now it's not even nuclear science
now you're a very powerful politician
and you actually have an maybe not an
nuclear scientist but least an atom
scientist sitting next to you have you
changed your view of being a politician
is it easier order when you thought well
I think my observation in the book and
doing the research on why we emptied our
own seize on fish when we have
scientists warning all the time and the
facts were actually on the table I think
but I sudden what I understand
understood in the end was that what was
lacking what was not the facts or the
science but it was actually the
political will to do something about it
and I think you need of course you need
good science you need good applications
but you also need the political side to
actually listen to the scientist I think
climate change is one of the most
obvious examples of that that we've had
the scientists warning about climate
change for so long time
but it took it took us more than 25
years of climate negotiations before we
had the climate agreement so I think
it's good that we have scientists and
people also from the outside coming into
politics because we need also people on
the inside to try to transform the
knowledge into action and that needs to
be in legislation it needs to be an
impractical agreements such as the Paris
agreement can I ask the whole theme for
this this dialogue is worth science
meets society do they and I mean in the
best of worlds it does and I think that
President Obama appointed you as the
Ministry of energies is fantastic and
Nobel laureate unfortunately we see now
some other appointments from the trumpet
administration that is not really based
on on on science when when it comes to
climate change I'm being a bit
diplomatic here you don't have to please
go ahead they told us you lie so that is
also a way of actually well showing
political leadership that you you take
science you take knowledge into your
your your craftsmanship of doing
legislation and doing what is needed and
with your application that you actually
can monitor now glaciers that that is a
beautiful story because it really comes
back to now we can actually see what's
happening with climate change and the
the glacier and the Arctic ice sheets
are no now at a historical low level not
only at its surface but also in its
depths or it so I guess that's one of
your applications what is I think one of
your applications is used and what is
your take I mean you'd sort of symbolize
this science mid society I guess in a
better way than most well I think
science
climate change you know misuse of the
ocean are two great examples where it
can formed informed society what is
happening and more important what are
the potential risks where the
uncertainties may be large but there are
huge a huge risks what society does with
this information is up to the political
systems you know they're doing there's
other legit there could be a little a
legitimate debate on what do you do
about the risks of climate change I
don't think it's a legitimate debate to
say whether it's happening or not or or
the fact that humans play a major if not
the major role in it and so it is a bit
worrisome that climate change is being
put in the same basket United States's
another crackpot theory like evolution
right obviously and what is the the
solution to that is it the scientist
that need to be better in explaining
like you and rock star murder what is
happening this is the facts or is it
politicians that need to really
understand the scientists well actually
I I when I was a journalist and I was
doing research on overfishing and the
state of our oceans I was very
frustrated with the scientist because I
tried to interview people saying what is
the overall view and all I could have a
fine where scientists are saying well I
actually I can't tell you that but i can
tell you something about acidification i
can tell you something about cod i can
tell you not all but all the code but
the chord in the baltic sea or actually
the code the code in the eastern Baltic
Sea so I mean scientists are very very
niche and they don't find very many of
them are not very comfortable with kind
of making an overall assumption of
something that also could be interpreted
as as political or an advice for
politicians so the ones that I find that
I really admire are the ones that have
the courage to also I mean and the
passion to to talk about their science
you know in a wider way
and not being so scared of going out of
the scientific role because then you can
actually really contribute to to
development and a number of scientists
are fantastic at doing that I think she
might be talking about you Stephen I'm
not sure the title of this session is
where will our food come from in the
future which is sort of a very open and
not very distinct a question if I were
to ask you to give us a very precise and
build answer to that question what would
you say Stephen well it precise both
it's a macro and a micro question as we
heard before we have the capacity to
feed 12 billion there's a distribution
wealth problem we have the pegasi to
increase that capacity you know
hopefully the population in the world
doesn't go over 10 billion but but there
are many other things having what to say
hopefully well I think when there's
rising prosperity in the world rising
education particularly among women much
less infant mortality there's
automatically birth control that goes
kicks in and i think you don't want to
have a whole world view and a world
economy based on a growing population so
more younger people take care of fewer
older people yes this is in y haces we
call this a Ponzi scheme and and
Sciences I think it's still called the
same so so so in there can be a world
where you have rising economic
prosperity but with your people but how
you manage that how you make but going
back to feeding the world things like
that if you can feed the world but if
you have industrial farming that there's
good weather here but not good weather
there and you can ship things around the
world at very low cost this does
something not so good to the local
population if you have a few bad years
of the local population agriculture
collapses their economy collapses
there the whole social structure
collapses the industry can feed the
world so you have to pay attention to
the micro part of this as well where
will the food come from that needs to be
introduced summer the sea that is in
silent anymore I think you raised some
very important points that I think on
gender equality that will be really a
crucial thing for the demographic
development but also on local production
of food and there I just want to say
that also wars and conflicts are the
major causes of food scarcity in the
world and starvation so I think we can
we can manage but we need to eat less
meat in the rich part of the world I
think in Africa at 17 kilos per person
and anum in Sweden is now 87 Wow and I
think in the american inn in the u.s. is
100 125 kilos or something and this is
really not sustainable we need to eat
less meat and more less many fifty
percent last ninety percent less look in
Sweden we have we ate around 60 kilos in
1990 and I didn't see anyone I'm just
under neutral I mean on starvation so I
mean we could eat a lot less and it's
not the role of the politician to decide
I think meat consumption has become a
status symbol led by the United States
unfortunately and so I think the outside
should lead in educating its
schoolchildren that this is not good for
your health it's not good for the planet
and so until the United States take some
leadership in that it will remain a
status symbol for developing countries
right I think we had a question from
from or actually question from us
answered by the audience maybe we should
have a quick look at the the result what
is the most important area for
policymakers need
to focus on food waste reduction good
work Tristan earlier here forty five
percent do you agree is it food waste
that is the most important area for
policymakers I mean we're producing
around twenty-five percent for the for
the waste bin and that is really not
sustainable so I think there's a lot
that can be done when it comes to
efficiency both in the food production
but also how we as consumers are acting
at home because a lot of waste is done
at home so we need a lot more
information and education on that bit
but I liked very much the animal welfare
also that because I think if we really
care about our animals then meet would
not be as cheap as it is now still in
short answer very quickly i would say
more on the nutritional side that it's
not just calories because empty calories
in developing countries lead to
remarkable rates of obesity I think it's
the richest food and how you do this and
I was a little bit astounded to learn at
that Apple that I used to think was good
food was something else was that they
have been on the shelf so long so but
nutrition and food is a big deal and and
it should be balanced in that you know
you're trying to raise healthy people
bad nutrition early in childhood is
really retard growth intellectual growth
physical growth everything societal
growth one final question if you were to
recommend us we're all sitting here and
one thing that we should think about to
be able to sort of confer to the
greatest benefit to mankind what would
you recommend us to do and you're not
allowed to say to become a Nobel
laureates or become a top politician I
think get engaged I think this is a
really important as this time of age now
where we saw so many of us feel that we
can just shower
our engagement through through internet
or Facebook and we like something which
is like something else but really the
meeting between people and getting
organized to really push for change that
is a negative system too well I think
you we see these societal problems and
to me you look at food and nutrition
land use energy water and it all is
really part and parcel one big problem
so how we go forward with science can
inform politicians science can also
develop new technologies to make better
solutions much more competitive so so
the older ways of doing business
actually don't stack up so there are
many things where remain an optimist and
what science can do stephen tomb is a
bit of living thank you so much for
coming and I hope you see you back
[Applause]